when it comes to big screen beatdowns
Bob Barker's brawl with hockey player
turned golfer Happy Gilmore is one for
the history bcks but believe it or not
the 1996 comedy wasn't the last time the
late game show host threw down with B
friendenemy Adam Sandler on August 26th
Legendary game show host Bob Barker
passed away from natural causes at the
age of 99 the longtime Entertainer was
best known as the host of the Price's
right one of the most moving
remembrances of Barker was a tribute
penned by Adam Sandler Sandler and
Barker after all had a unique
relationship owing to their time
sparring buddies indeed for fans of a
certain age Barker will always be
remembered for his hilarious Cameo and
Happy Gilmore Sandler stars is a failed
hockey player with a killer Slap Shot a
temper and zero affinity for ice skating
when he needs to come up with the cash
to save his grandmother's house from
foreclosure happy turns to g a sport at
which he surprisingly excels happy
skills lead him to the Pepsi proam
tournament where he's partnered with Bob
Barker soon the men are sand trapped
deep and around of fisticuffs for Happy
Gilmore fans and critics alike the fight
scene is a highlight with variety
calling it one of the movies inspired
laps even the biggest Happy Gilmore
devotees might not know that Barker and
Sandler reunited in 2015 for a rematch
in the name of Charity of course in
support of comedy Central's Knight of
too many stars fundraiser for autism
Charities the duo appeared in a 4-minute
video while the Happy Gilmore scene
Minds humor from The Familiar usually
friendly faces in the state environment
of a golf course the video takes place
in a setting even less amenable to fist
fights a hospital room directed by Tyler
spindle the night of too many stars
fight begins with Sandler visiting
Barker in the hospital attempting to
bury the hatchet almost 20 years after
their violent meeting but old habits die
hard teasing turns to ruthless barbs
turns to Sandler sucker punching Barker
in his hospital bed the fight is even
more ridiculous than the golf course
squabble with Hospital props like
prosthetic legs and a vase of bedside
flowers being reappropriated as Weapons
I can't let you die on me I'm sorry come
back and let me finish your
ass at one point Barker flat Lins then
pops up zombie like to dump his bed pan
over Sandler's head the fight ends in
comic fashion with Barker infecting the
two of them with ebola even as angels in
heaven where Carl Weathers shows up in a
cameo the pair comes to blows yet again
with Barker delivering the final wallup
with his heart for those keeping score
that's Barker 2 Sandler zero if the
rematch was anything like the original
fight that was Barker's doing Barker had
a Happy Gilmore stipulation that he
would only appear in the film if he won
the fight moreover he was gung-ho to do
the fighting himself stunt doubles be
damned now you've had
enough
director Dennis Dugan told crack he was
completely game for it he got the joke
but he was totally up for it also he'd
studied martial arts as a hobby forever
so even though he was about 70 he really
could kick ass even at 91 Bob Barker was
raring to go in the Battle Royale Redux
that should come as no surprise given
his affection for Happy Gilmore for the
game show host his famed fight scene
revitalized his career among a younger
demographic between the films released
in 1996 and his retirement from the
prices right in 2007 younger fans often
came up to him to ask him about about
his Happy Gilmore cameo in 2014 Barker
told people they asked me all sorts of
things the young men would ask me in
real life could you really whip Adam
Sandler I would tell them are you
kidding Adam Sandler couldn't whip Regis
filin I'm in fighting frame fit to fight
Barker's KN of too many stars appearance
wasn't the first time he recreated his
famous cameo in a 2014 episode of The
Bold and the Beautiful Barker recreated
the scene with Wyatt Spencer played by
Darren Brooks in the same people
interview Barker explained I thought it
was a wonderful idea because Happy
Gilmore is still playing on television
frequently and everybody loved that
fight scene for bold and beautiful to be
so bold as to copy more or less is
wonderful I've still got
it